[Music]
workplace vaccine mandates are becoming
increasingly common and of course
controversial with canada's employment
minister carla qualtro warning that
unvaccinated workers who lose their jobs
may not be eligible for ei
but is this even permitted under the
rule of law let's bring in employment
lawyer leora samfiro who knows the
answer let's talk about this can workers
who are denied
or rather who are laid off because they
refuse the vaccine can they have access
to employment insurance
so anthony we've heard those comments
from the minister but it is important to
understand that at this point all it is
is comments in order for this type of a
chain to deprive people of ei there
would have to be a legislative change
there would actually have to be amended
amendments to the employment insurance
act and that's not something we've heard
happening so far the way the law
currently works is an employee gets
deprived of ei if they do something that
essentially makes it impossible for the
employer to continue employing them now
with respect to vaccination it is really
right now an employer's choice to let
the employee go it's not something that
the employer must do if there's no
government mandate so the basic
principle would be that an employee
right now should still qualify for ei if
in fact they choose not to be vaccinated
unless there's a government mandate if
that changes it would require
legislative change at this point we have
not heard of that happening
so let's talk about severance then what
happens in that case because i know
we've talked about this before
but are they entitled to it and does you
know getting vaccinated or not does that
impact
so severance is a big issue a lot of
people have already lost their jobs or
been suspended and definitely because
they've chosen not to be vaccinated but
here's where we go back to what i said
earlier about a government landing
whenever there's no government mandate
that means that it's the employer
choosing to let the employee go they
don't have to and in that situation the
laws of severance would say that yes an
employee that chooses not to be
vaccinated should get severance so for
most of these individuals unless the
employer really can show that there was
no choice an employee that loses their
job because of the vaccine or because of
their employer's vaccine mandate is
entitled to their full severance up to
two years pay
so a big warning really to
employers and companies given this
because a lot of companies are trying to
enact this but they're not doing so
legally correct
that's exactly right i don't think that
employers understand and appreciate the
exposure the financial exposure they
have important for those employers to
get some advice as well so we're talking
about the legality of the vaccine
mandate but the sort connects in many
ways to the viability because in terms
of the vaccine mandate we saw it in
health care or you know long-term care
it was attempted in certain health care
settings but we're seeing as well
because of labor shortages a lot of
these places have to bring back alberta
inviting their 1400 health care workers
now niagara health doing the same for
its nearly 200 workers
so you translate that into the overall
workforce that could have a huge impact
i think absolutely employers are
struggling to keep people so if they end
up losing more people because of the
vaccine and also have to pay them uh for
that privilege so to speak that may
actually have the the effect of putting
a lot of businesses under which is
simply bad for everyone
all right so let's talk shift gears for
a moment and kids have returned to
remote learning this week what rights do
working parents have if they're based in
the office but of course needs to take
care of their children
so in ontario we have something called
the infectious disease emergency leave
which means that a parent does have a
right if their kid has no school schools
are closed to stay home with their child
they have a job protected leave of
absence which means the employer cannot
punish them or do anything to them in
that situation even if your child is
older as long as you're under the age of
18 a parent has a right to stay home
with their kids as long as those schools
are closed
uh real quick i want to ask in terms of
you know what employers can do or need
to do for uh for their employees given
all this so under human rights of the
legislation employer does who have to
accommodate family responsibilities
couple of things that come to mind is
allowing employees to work from home
where that is possible that's very
important another thing of course is to
change work hours if needed to allow
employees to still meet those financial
and family obligations so there is that
duty to accommodate of course that
employers can't simply choose to ignore
we appreciate this as always shedding
light on some very important issues that
is our employment lawyer leor semf
you're always a pleasure sir
thank you